before we cut to the panel of deplore
walls we have to have the roaming
millennial lightning round okay
I have arranged the most important
questions summer dichotomies some are
just regular questions I want the first
answer that comes to your mind you know
don't think it out just let it come come
right out and this I think will give us
a portrait I think roaming millennial
his favorite youtuber it's our kind of a
Cod favorite now what about me I guess
I'm not really YouTube's favorite novel
I'm you should say favorite novel see
that's really really harsh for strolling
part part of me is day by day Armageddon
a zombie novel the other part of me is I
really like Pride and Prejudice it's I
pass too many all the men prejudice I
believe that I could see that a mile
away
favorite movie um I want to say
something for profound and intellectual
seeming but honestly Lord of the Rings
the second one the second you know I
walk down yeah it was so bored in the
woods we'll talk about it later
fortune or reddit reddit Spencer Clavin
or Richard Spencer um
Oh Richard Spencer because I want to
convince some of the beauties of
race-mixing
a noble and and thing that I don't want
to think about holy quran Duran Duran
Duran Duran all right all wrong my
country right or wrong my country went
right my country run right when right
William F Buckley William F Buckley
William F Buckley always you're just
going right for it very courageous
political views favorite color well
somehow - - what a coincidence we've so
much in common
celebrity crush Bear Grylls great
senator Graham senator Wow that that's a
hard one Rand Paul maybe read plainly
progressed yeah Michael Lee is a hottie
Rand Paul I feel like he's got a good
heart Wow Orange Crush were great Crush
Orange Crush no the correct answer was
great favorite philosopher um Smith in
terms of governments Aquinas in terms of
I guess the nature of man typing he's
still my beating heart
mercy to the guilty is cruelty to the
innocent if you've never read any Smith
and no one has keep that in mind like
everyone reads Smith that's kind of the
intro everyone says they read Smith how
many people on earth have ever read The
Wealth of Nations they've read about it
but how many people have actually
I feel like any you know like 100 level
Western philosophy or intro to
government class you have to read well
Yale the only mandated classes are
oppression in gender studies so that
would be that's progress know not to
write class now that's gonna replace the
whole curricula weirdest thing a YouTube
commenter has ever said or asked of you
all right there are quite a few
questions about my feet about your feet
yeah like I'll be on a live stream and
there will be a sizable amount of people
asking me to show them my feet that does
this come out if your political
discussions that you have been is this
esoteric well yeah maybe that's just it
Occam's razor well that is pretty I
never get those questions I mean it's a
part of me like oh well it could be
worse the other part of me it's kind of
like maybe it's it is that much worse
I'm just not seeing it yeah that's
that's true it seems innocent on the
surface maybe maybe a really deep
political question underneath and maybe
just kind of weird how much Kofa a would
a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could
cook off fa a big li amount thickly
absolutely right she nailed it
absolutely